los brutales enfrentamientos entre la
fuerza pública los manifestantes
liderados por la conaie indígena dejan
ya varios muertos y más de un centenar
de heridos
una represión que ha elevado el tono de
las marchas que iniciaron por la
carestía del combustible y los productos
agrícolas
no queremos ya el gobierno si no quiso
dialogar en los primeros días nosotros
pensamos que este gobierno ya no es el
pueblo más bien este gobierno representa
los grandes
empresas neoliberales lo cual nos
explotan
nos
precarizan laboralmente el viernes el
presidente ecuatoriano guillermo lasso
denuncia un intento de golpe de estado
está comprobado que la intención
verdadera de los violentos es generar un
golpe de estado y por eso hacemos un
llamado a la comunidad internacional
para advertir de este intento de
desestabilizar la democracia en el
ecuador junto al ministerio del interior
laso evalúa el uso de armamento letal
perdigones para repeler a los
manifestantes la policía nacional y la
fuerza armada
actuarán con los medios necesarios para
defender dentro del marco legal
mediante el uso progresivo de la fuerza
el orden público y la democracia varias
organizaciones internacionales de
derechos humanos se han denunciado
violaciones de derechos en la respuesta
de la fuerza pública a la protesta
señalando a la policía como los autores
del asesinato de un comunero por un
disparo en la cabeza con un cilindro de
gas lacrimógeno debido a la precisión
profundidad y dirección de la
perforación en el cráneo corroboradas
con testimonios consideramos que el
disparo fue hecho a corta distancia en
trayectoria recta y horizontal estos
elementos son indicadores claros del uso
excesivo de la fuerza el movimiento
indígena exige que se respete el pliego
de 10 peticiones para sentarse a la mesa
de negociación